a grieving mother and her
child a 40-year-old husband and father
of four shot dead in his field funerals
for Palestinians killed by Israeli
settlers in the occupied West Bank are
increasingly common these days since
Israel's war on Gaza
began we took our food and children down
to the olive trees we had been there an
hour when suddenly we saw them running
towards us my husband said to take the
kids away so we ran but he had forgotten
his phone and went back to get it he
bent down to pick it up and they shot
him this is his body lying among the
olive trees shot twice in the
chest he wanted to make olive oil he
planted herbs and season to sell so he
can feed his sons this Olive season he
said they might not have enough
he was just trying to provide for his
family Yosi dager is the elected
chairman of the shaan Regional Council
responsible for 35 illegal Israeli
settlements in the northern occupied
West
Bank after the media started reporting
below's death Dagan recorded a statement
describing the Palestinian farmer as a
terrorist who had threatened the lives
of settlers close by this video was
filmed by one of a number of
Palestinians who witnessed the
incident gunfire can be heard armed
settlers are seen close to where bow was
killed we came up here we didn't know
what was happening the soldiers are
standing looking forward they saw bow
but they did nothing the rights
organization yesh Dean monitored 1, 1597
investigations of Israeli settler
violence committed against Palestinians
between the years years 2005 and
2022 only 3% of those investigations led
to a conviction an off-duty Israeli
soldier has been arrested on suspicion
of shooting Bal but the human rights
lawyer aad Hadad says the chances of
Justice are
remote the regime the courts and the
police are completely useless at this
time of war in Gaza settler violence is
increasing the situation is so bad that
Israeli police are hard responding to
complaints made by Palestinians who
suffer violence bal's family and friends
now join the many other thousands of
Palestinians who gave up hope for
justice long ago Charles stford Al jazer
a sa in the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer